if lupine is your idea of a good time
you are in luck because we've got five
more picks that are criminally
entertaining on this week's bench guide
the first part of netflix's french crime
caper lupin is an
international sensation with a certified
fresh 97
on the tomato meter and over 70 million
streams in its first month
omar sai's incredible performance as the
gentleman thief
diop has fans saying sacre blue and the
show has been called
nearly perfect by critics so if you are
a fan of smooth criminals we have five
more titles that are sure to steal your
heart
starting with our family friendly pick
lupin the third the first
this 3d animated entry to the iconic
manga series offers the smoothness of
james bond and the action of indiana
jones in a globetrotting adventure
fitting for the master thief lupin iii
and one that kids and adults will
equally adore plus with
many more installments including heyo
miyazaki's directorial debut there's
plenty to love in the world of lupin iii
with a certified fresh 95 critics call
loop in the third
an absolute blast helped by beautiful
animation which lets
zany hijinks dazzle brighter than ever
and in just an hour and a half this one
is easier to watch than stealing candy
from a baby
next up is our audience pick and it is
going to another netflix sensation
la casa de papel aka money heist another
international netflix breakout money
heist follows the dramatic twists and
shocking turns that unfold after a group
of bank robbers attempt the largest bank
heist in history with complex characters
non-linear storytelling and a distinct
visual style it's no surprise fans love
money heists giving it an average 81
across the first four seasons critics
have called money heist a twisty
thriller that's vibrant and addictive
with an ingenious plot and engaging
characters
with four seasons and a fifth on the way
it'll take you about 30 hours to binge
this one but you'll be ready to carry
out the crime of the century afterwards
so trust me it's worth it
next up is our throwback pick and we're
going all the way back to the original
tv
thief the saint this 60s classic stars a
pre james bond roger moore as simon
templar
a scofflaw with a strict moral compass
that always has noble reason for his
criminal behavior with a classic british
tongue-in-cheek attitude the saint is a
far cry from spy thriller but it offers
roger moore's trademark charisma in
spades
with 118 episodes you're looking at just
over 100 hours to watch all of the saint
and you'll be armed with enough
one-liners to last a lifetime
next up is our editor's pick and it is
going to the tnt drama series
leverage this series follows a team of
unlikely high-tech robin hoods as they
target big corporations and financial
organizations that have victimized
the everyman featuring a menagerie of
characters armed with all the tools of
the trade
critics call leverage compelling and a
twisty exciting caper series
with five seasons it'll take you just
over three days to watch all of leverage
after which you'll finally understand
why a bunch of redditors
wanted to take down wall street and last
but certainly
not least is our brand new pick thieves
of the wood this 10 part belgian
historical drama tells the story of 18th
century outlaw
john delayed and his gang as they
perform robin hood like duties and stand
up for the oppressed
lower class villagers although we don't
have a critics consensus the show boasts
an 84
audience rating and is said to be
lovingly designed with strong
performances throughout
it'll take you about 10 hours to binge
thieves of the wood after which you'll
wonder how the writers on all these
international netflix shows are just so
good at writing crime shows it's like
they have first-hand experience or
something
alright friends so hopefully this list
presented you with a couple of
high-profile targets for your next
streaming score be sure to let us know
what you
are currently streaming in the comments
section and also if you didn't know we
actually have a podcast called rotten
tomatoes is wrong so definitely check
that out because new episodes drop every
thursday and fresher run is just the
beginning of the conversation and of
course if you don't want to miss out on
any recommendations based around the
movies and shows that you love
be sure to hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always
can't thank you enough for tuning into
the rotten tomatoes binge guide and
we'll see you next time
bye
you